mr. Eastwood taka talk to us how did you
first hear about the project and and you
know what the connection that you most
responded to was was I knew they were
gonna make this picture I had read in
the trades that they were going to make
it and so I thought I'd read the book
but nobody I knew somebody else was
doing it so I didn't think too much of
it I just read it for my for fun and
then all of a sudden well I'm reading it
Dan filmin from Warner Brothers calls me
up and said you know I'm reading the
book right now and he said well would
you be interested in doing it and I said
wait a second somebody else is doing no
no that's that's fell through and we'd
like you to consider it so I said well
let me finish the last 30 pages I'll
call you right back
so I did I finished sat down finished
him called him right back so but it was
it was an interesting thing and and I
saw that guy who's killed 160 people
that's only the affirmed ones the ones
firmed by a senior officer confirmed
rather I said and I thought that guy's
got to have some baggage in there and
you've got to have some thoughts about
it and how does a person feel like that
and how do you when does it become do
you give do you do you do it for fun I
mean if like what it wouldíve reactions
I met everybody would probably go
through different periods that way in
fact one of my favorite scenes in the
picture it was at the end when he's
talking to psychiatrist and the
psychiatrist was asking him did you ever
think you did some things that you
regret well you were over there and and
Bradley says no no I go to my Maker
confident but he look at his eyes and
you can tell he's he's not quite be
telling the truth a right Jason Knight I
believe you have some background as an
actor yourself and so I wonder does that
inform the way that you write characters
for others to portray can you just as
that I mean I imagine it must every all
life experiences
we play into it but is that one of them
you know I I am interested in character
first it's it's I come from that
background certainly and I'm interested
in mythology I'm interested in in the
hero's journey and for Chris you know it
was important to create that and to
jumpstart it off the bat this was a war
that you know we we had a lot of
feelings about this country has a lot of
feelings about that warrant so for me it
was if we could centralize a moral
dilemma for this character off the top
of the movie jump start him and the
audience into this and say look there's
a lot more to this than you know for
these guys a lot goes into this you know
it's these guys come back with a lot of
baggage and it's not necessarily the
blood it's not necessarily the guts but
it's this moral dilemma that they face
as soldiers everyday you know to do what
what they came here to do to do what
they know is right but right gets really
gray when you get over there and you
know I I love the idea of this sheepdog
who goes over there and and the sheepdog
is is doing what he can and doing what
he can but then it turns into like
losing friends and vengeance and the
sheepdog becomes that he's hunting it at
one point in the movie you know and he
becomes the wolf and and how he finds
his way back from that is is really
gratifying and and it wasn't something
that I had to make up you know now we're
in the prize where was everybody here in
the process when you got the news that
this terrible tragedy had happened and
he'd been he had been killed what where
how far along was the project and and
we're you know how did it obviously
first and foremost it's it's just a
terrible thing but in terms of telling
his story how did you then move forward
I had been in communication with Chris
the whole time and this is our part I I
texted him and I said I'm turning in
your script and he said good luck with
that I hope you work again and then I
made a joke that you know I will not
Pete it's I learned how to make Chris
Kyle laugh and it was it was a point of
pride for me you know it took a while
and and I think maybe he was just
laughing more in general but uh I made a
joke and he said lol and I turned in the
script I gave the script to the
producers on Friday and the next day was
Saturday and I got a call on Saturday
and they said Chris was just murdered
and you know you spend your time in this
guy's head and getting to know him and
then him becoming a friend at the same
time that you you take him on and and
maybe I do it a little more as an actor
but you know I try and get into the head
of this guy and try to live it and man
you know I just wept like a baby I just
wept and it was uh I called Bradley and
and we sat on the phone he had been at a
at the VA and in Washington DC that day
and he spent the whole day with these
vets and then he came out and got this
phone call that Chris had been murdered
and it was really rough you know it was
rough so ya know when you when you
joined the project were you able to also
reach out to Ted and take away things
that you could apply to your performance
or trail of her and also and
specifically in the final I guess the
final scene when taya says goodbye to
Chris there is something I thought going
on in the look that you give him and I
wondered if that was deliberate almost
as if you know that there's something
coming and just where you know the
thought process there I did spend a lot
of time with taya we I was in London
before I started shooting and Clint
doesn't rehearse which is it was just an
amazing way of working but I spoke to
her via Skype which is the wonder of the
modern world and then when I got to LA
two weeks before we started shooting we
spent a lot of time together there and
she's you know I had to bear in mind
that she's obviously a very different
woman now to the woman that she was when
I was playing her because she's in the
middle of this incredible grief and it's
so recent this happened last year you
know it's unbelievable but she's still
managed to retain
this kind of energy and openness and
because she never knew whether Chris
would come home she kept everything so
there was an immense amount of source
material every single email that they
ever wrote to each other
Bradley and I read if she filmed him all
the time and and and was just very open
and understanding I'm and I was a new
mother at the time when I started
shooting this and you know it's that's
impossible for any woman it's a really
complicated time and beautiful but hard
but to try and understand what it would
be like to be raising two children on
your own and not knowing every single
day whether your husband would survive
was a really interesting headspace to
get into and she was so brilliant and
helpful and that last look was something
that couldn't added completely off the
cuff it was one take it wasn't I mean I
he just said when you look out the door
just look and just get it just give me a
sense that something might be wrong just
some sense of intuition and
interestingly when Chris actually did go
out with that guy he phoned ter from the
gun range and said something's wrong I
don't know what it is but something's up
but I'll be home soon and that was the
last time they spoke and I I feel like
it was maybe a nod to that moment they
couldn't ask me to do that
there seemed to be certain patterns of
things that interest you in terms of
what pops up in the films that you
choose to make obviously we've seen
various aspects of war and also violence
and and and killing things that you're
exploring the different sides of and I
think many of the films that you've
acted in and certainly also Unforgiven I
think was the ultimate exploration of
that and is that over analyzing it or is
are those themes and subjects that you
really are intrigued by no I'm intrigued
by it and because unforgiven character
is there he's got a new new guy who just
became who just killed somebody and then
and he's having terrible regrets about
it it's folding up completely and they
have so it's you know you've you know
and you have the old-time guy which is
me it was telling him about
yeah that's a hell of a thing to kill
somebody and you know there's a lot a
lot goes on and and I thought about that
a lot during and this filming this
picture too because a lot must have
going on even though that these people
are the enemy they're killing people
that are just military aged men on the
street they don't know for a fact that
maybe it's somebody who just made a
mistake and walked out there or four or
whatever but for that but they have a go
ahead to knock somebody off who just
happens to me to be there now whether is
there they just they just kind of
figured the odds are these they're for
no good and and and when Sienna
mentioned then that last thing to is I
have a great respect for intuition and
women's intuition and and I thought that
I would just kind of do the door thing I
just kind of pull the curtain on it's
like the last time she's ever gonna see
him and something's something's amiss
and so I tried to use that that movement
to sell that fact and but those are
things she says I made it up on the spot
but you're always making up something on
the spot so and so that's what's fun
about making films you can you have a
you have a plan but the plan there's
always subject to whatever you you find
it and whatever you're learning yourself
about the people about the performers
how they're treating the people it's
always just an evolving process so it's
great fun that's why I'm still doing it
at 28